hello again friends hopefully you all
have had a chance to see Captain America
the Winter Soldier if you haven't don't
worry I have a spoiler free review go
ahead check that out that'll be fun for
you then watch the movie because it's
awesome then come back here and watch
this video three bits entertainment for
you guys point is Captain America the
Winter Soldier it's necessary to do a
spoiler video on there's gonna be a
heavy spoiler filled video so to get dil
watches if you haven't watch the movie
it's necessary because things I wanted
to talk about my review I really
couldn't I needed to give props that I
couldn't give props to without it being
a spoiler example props to the chemistry
with all the characters in the movie in
that point you got it mentioned Steve
Rogers and Scarlett Johansson you know
Black Widow their chemistry was great I
liked how they interacted together like
just the small examples when they're in
the mall and trying to evade the
douchebag she's like kiss me public
displays of affection to make people
uncomfortable so he has to kiss her and
sure enough the guy turns away I like
stuff like that when you're evading
people I like it when someone's smart
enough to use human psychology to
actually evade people I just put on a
ball cap and be like uh
and conspicuous this movie put black
widow in the forefront for males like
that chicks awesome I was always knew
she was hot is scarlet Joe we all love
scarlet Joe but she is a formidable and
badass Avenger I'm just saying I'd I
almost would like to see her in her own
movie most of all for me guys this is
the movie this is the best Nick Fury
film I've ever seen of all the Marvel
movies Nick Fury was the most badass the
most relevant and the deepest character
he's ever been I couldn't say that dogs
if I was like Nick Fury is so great he
steps it up in this movie he is in the
forefront also at a point when he's dead
he'd be like wait a minute Jeremy said
he's awesome in this movie he hasn't
really been awesome yet which means he's
alive yeah Cielo compliment could be a
spoiler it's why I got a hold back
sometimes he was honestly great and a
lot of people were like I knew he wasn't
dead they're not gonna kill him off I
have been thinking for a while like I
wonder how long samuel l.jackson is
gonna actually be Nick Fury in these
movies I think Captain America is
wearing his director of shield outfit in
this movie I'm like I may be he just
dies in this one so when he died I
thought Nick Fury was actually dead to
the fact that he wasn't dead I was like
okay but above all else I give this
movie credit for the ball this movie had
balls do you find out in this movie that
Hydra has been growing inside shield for
a long time like this political parasite
it's just it's rooted in there like I
said the Winter Soldier he's cool
because he's there to cause problems but
he's not the
guy the bad guys were actually the good
guys and that's a moral shade of gray
that goes on what Steve Rogers has to
deal with now he's like I fought a war
because I wanted to because it was
honorable because I wanted to serve my
country but that's not what we do now
war has changed the political [ __ ]
pulling the strings they get
power-hungry and they become douchebags
and now they're the bad guys sometimes
you work for them but that doesn't
change the fact that they're bad guy
Captain America is like I don't care if
I work for you you're a bad guy you're
an [ __ ] I'm gonna take you down
that's what he does Hydra shield we're
burning it all to the ground and pissing
on the ashes so by the end of this movie
you're like I'd shield is gone which
makes me wonder how the rest of these
Marvel movies are gonna go without
shield like is agents of shield
cancelled now how can you have agents of
shield when you don't have a shield to
have agents of shield his agents of
shields gonna touch on the fact that
there's no longer any shield or is there
a shield oh and I just think that
there's no shield it makes you think
about where things are gonna go now I
mean I imagine yeah they'll restructure
they'll rebuild it and you know for the
good guys so the Winter Soldier we know
is his friend Bucky from Captain America
1 you know the dude that fell off the
train and died and that one segment that
totally reminds me of uncharted 2 yeah
did the train scene in uncharted 2 it is
so bummer is I had that spoiled for me
when the first trailer came out was
there a Winter Soldier and I googled
Winter Soldier dumb thing to do I guess
I just thought he was some [ __ ] but I
didn't know does a friend Bucky so I see
a picture of the dude from Captain
America why it's like Bucky is the
Winter Soldier Oh like I didn't want to
know that careful what you google which
is a rule of thumb that we all know it's
just one of those things where it's just
you don't think it's important and then
it is but Captain America doesn't want
to kill this guy but this guy clearly
wants to kill Captain America by the end
of the movie you can tell the Winter
Soldier is like I'm not gonna kill you
I'm gonna kick your [ __ ] balls in
you're not dead so by the end of the
movie he puts Steve Rogers down he's
walks I was gonna go figure out his [ __ ]
which makes me interested as to if he's
gonna pop up again which I get excited
for because I'm like who were they gonna
have in the Marvel movies to come
wouldn't that be so awesome and Avengers
2 we're talking all of the Avengers from
the first Avengers movie and all the
sidekicks they've accrued thus far war
machine Bucky everyone's just going
after bad dudes why were some
intergalactic [ __ ] I would never mess
with this planet ever bloosh credits
scenes are interesting but post credits
scenes are only so interesting at this
point for me nothing will ever beat the
first time you saw samuel l.jackson as
Nick Fury say he's here to talk about
the Avengers initiative ever since that
it's a series of things that are just
not as good however we do get a glimpse
of Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch which
is actually pretty cool I'll play Marvel
heroes you know who Scarlet Witch is you
don't well she's in there just funny
because Quicksilver is actually in Days
of Future past also and this one he
can't be a mutant I guess because
mutants are 20th century fox twentieth
century fox it interesting for me like
that's weird that you can have the same
guy he's just not done in the same way
in which case can we have a guy named
Wolverine who has claws coming out of
his hands but he's not a mitten so it's
kind of not the same then we can have
Spider Man but he wasn't bitten by a
radioactive spider so it's different
looks like there's this shade of grey
among contracts and characters that can
be in movies and whatnot so can we do
that can we just have everyone I say we
do and if you can't do it anyway yeah
you'll get sued to [ __ ] you'll hate it
financially but we'll love you for it
I love the fact that he gets his old
costume from World War 2 in this movie I
mean the new outfits great and all but
my favorite outfit Captain America has
ever had it was the one in the first
Captain America movie it was cool it was
just like World War 2 tak and straps I
was like how are they gonna make a
Captain America suit look good and it
looks like it belongs in World War 2 him
like that looks good everything in this
movie I felt was optimised to be the
best thing it could possibly be in his
movie Captain America the Winter Soldier
was great I loved it it was one of those
movies I walked out of this movie with
the same feeling I had when I walked out
of the first Ironman I'd say it's
Avengers Iron Man and Captain America
the Winter Soldier those are my three
favorite Marvel movies so Captain
America the Winter Soldier have you seen
it what did you think about whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more